HE WAS VERY CONFIDENT THAT THE
SYRIAN REGIME WAS BEHIND THAT
CHEMICAL ATTACK ON APRIL 4TH.
LAURA.
>> JENNIFER GRIFFIN, THANK YOU
SO MUCH.
AND JOINING US NOW, CHRIS AND
FORMER INTEL OFFICER.
GREAT TO SEE YOU TONIGHT.
WE ALWAYS PRAY FOR OUR TROOPS IN
HARM'S WAY ON NIGHTS LIKE
TONIGHT.
LET'S GET YOUR SENSE ON THIS.
WE WERE TALKING A LITTLE EARLIER
ABOUT SYRIA, LIKE IRAQ,
EXTREMELY COMPLICATED PLACE.
I THINK WE IN AMERICA THINK OF
THE MIDDLE EAST ALL AS ONE
PLACE.
AND IT'S THE EXACT OPPOSITE OF
THAT.
IT'S LIKE 100 PLACES.
TELL US ABOUT SYRIA ON THE
GROUND AND YOUR VIEW OF WHAT
HAPPENED TONIGHT.
>> WHAT HAPPENED TONIGHT,
LAURA, WHAT I KNOW AND I CAN SEE
IS THAT THIS IS NOT A U.S./SYRIA
OPERATION.
THIS IS NOT THE INVASION OF IRAQ
AND AFGHANISTAN.
THIS IS A VERY SPECIFIC STRIKE
ABOUT THE ASSAD REGIME
CAPACITIES TO DELIVER CHEMICAL
WEAPONS.
WE CANNOT JUDGE TONIGHT.
IF THE SYRIAN REGIME DECIDES TO
STOP USING IT, OPERATION IS
OVER.
IF THERE ARE REACTIONS, WHICH I
ANTICIPATE NOT NECESSARILY IN
DAMASCUS BUT OTHER PARTS OF
SYRIA, IT'S A DIFFERENT STORY.
>> I WOULD HAVE TO DEGREE.
AND WE DID THREE PRECISION
ATTACKS WITH FACILITIES WITH
SARIN GAS, WHICH HAS A HIGH
DENSITY AND BURNOFF RATE.
IF THEY TAKE THIS AS THE MESSAGE
IT WAS MEANT TO BE, THEN THIS
COULD RESOLVE ITSELF RATHER
QUICK.
OPTIMISTICALLY, I DON'T THINK
SO.
I THINK ASSAD WILL REACT AND
WE'LL SEE WHAT HAPPENS TOMORROW
MORNING.
>> CHRIS, APPARENTLY, WE HIT A
NUMBER OF STORAGE FACILITIES.
MY QUESTION IS, IF WE KNEW THE
-- THIS MIGHT BE A REALLY DUMB
QUESTION.
BUT IF YOU KNOW THE STORAGE
FACILITIES ARE THERE, AND WE
THOUGHT THEY DESTROYED THE
WEAPONS PREVIOUSLY, WE LAUNCHED
OUR STRIKES LAST YEAR, WHY
DIDN'T WE DO A PREEMPTIVE
STRIKE?
WHY DID WE WAIT UNTIL 40 PEOPLE
WERE KILLED?
>> THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION.
I LEARNED A LOT FROM BEING
AROUND HIM.
BUT I THINK THAT WE LOOKED AT
THE APPROACH AND THE DUE
DILIGENCE OF HAVING THOSE
WALKUPS AND HAVING ALL THOSE
WE KNOW WHAT THIS IS.
AND THEY'VE HAD PLENTY OF
OPPORTUNITIES.
SO RIGHT NOW THE QUANTITY OF THE
STRIKE HAS INCREASED, SO WE'RE
HITTING THOSE FACILITIES
DESIGNED TO PREVENT THOSE
AERIAL FROM DOING IT AGAIN.
>> WE TALKED ABOUT THIS
EARLIER.
MY QUESTION IS A SIMPLE ONE.
WE HAVE AN INTERNATIONAL
CONSENSUS AGAINST THE USE OF
CHEMICAL WEAPONS, SARIN GAS.
I DON'T THINK -- CAN WE THINK OF
A TIME IN WORLD HISTORY WHERE
SARIN GAS AND CHLORINE WERE USED
AT THE SAME TIME?
I DON'T THINK SO.
WEIRD.
THAT'S JUST WEIRD.
WE HAVE AN INTERNATIONAL
CONSENSUS YOU CAN'T USE THIS.
WE'VE GOT CHILDREN DYING, THESE
VIDEOS,
WHERE IN THE INTERNATIONAL
COMMUNITY?
WHY DOES THE UNITED STATES HAVE
TO CARRY THE LOAD FOR EVERYONE
WHEN THE UNITED STATES HAS A
HUGE DEBT LEVEL?
I'M NOT SAYING WE DON'T HAVE A
MORAL DUTY, BUT WE HAVE A MORAL
DUTY TO THE NEXT GENERATION AND
THE GENERATION AFTER THAT, THAT